Break out the colored smencils.
So you can send all your friends a Post Carden...?
Because LUT Is back...
Use this Pin Press Storage device to create
your own shaped shelves or just make a huge
shelf shaped like yourself.
Where you can store all your gold-plated toilet
paper.
If you can't afford that type of bathroom
bling get some colored toilet paper that comes
in blue, fusia, lime green, orange, red, and
black.
Keep yourself busy with some kinetic sand
that you can shape and squeeze without losing
a grain because of a secret binding agent
that keeps the granules together.
After playing in the sand throw your clothes
into the washing machine.....laundry hamper.
And take a bath with your loved ones in this
Yin Yang bathtub equipped with bubble massage
and a rainbow of colored lights to choose
from.
If that's not enough add this underwater disco
ball for the ultimate bath tub party.
And pull out your inflatable couch bed that
you set conveniently next to your dog's murphy
wall bed.
For a little more privacy just put on these
SleepPhones headphones which are headphones
nestled inside a cozy headband which you can
connect to an audio jack or any bluetooth-enabled
device.
For the ultimate sleeping experience, sleep
inside a bear.....shaped sleeping bag.
And strap on your squirrel wingsuit so you
can jump off of cliffs, and soar.
Squirrel is a company created by base jumpers
who strive to make suits that give the user
the ability to base jump safely and efficiently.
You may be dreaming of being a flying squirrel
because you're using this lucid dream inducer.
Luci is an advanced lucid dream inducer that
uses brain waves to detect REM sleep and uses
the vocal alert "This is a dream.
Take Control" so you can then start controlling
your dreams.
Now wake up and use this giant giraffe coffee
cup.
Or just have some coffee like a Norseman in
this viking horn.
Test your cake without ruining it with this
cake pan that makes a mini cake to sample
on the side.
When it's ready you can serve it on these
I 8 SUM PI plates.
And do some heavy lifting with these construction
plate utensils.
Have your dessert and drink it too with these
cocktail Jellies that come in mojito and singapore
sling.
Set your drink down on these glowing radioactive
elements coasters that come in Radium, Plutonium,
Uranium, and Thorium.
Or just drink them like a Pro with this Golf
Club drink dispenser.
Speaking of woods check out these Neighborwoods.
Clever art pieces created by Aymie Spitzer
by laser engraving your favorite neighborhood
into cedar like Brooklyn, Atlanta, Chicago,
and New Orleans.
For going out on the town instead just put
on your Ryan Gosling earrings.
And your Hello Kitty contacts lenses.
But don't forget this iphone case that comes
equipped with pepper spray so you can protect
yourself that way or by dropping an F bomb.....
paperweight.
That sounds dangerous so stay in and build
this DIY arcade cabinet.
The Porta-Pi is for the Raspberry Pi and comes
with all the parts you need and instructions
on how to construct your own.
Or use the Touch Board to transform touch
into sound.
It's a tool to make your projects interactive,
responsive, smart, and fun and can turn almost
any surface or material into a sensor like
this wall which was turned into a talking
alphabet.
Finally, light your projects with this inflatable
light bag.
Or melt this cat into a skeleton.
And as always.... thanks for watching.